Il paraitrait qu'on connaît mieux notre système
solaire que les fonds marins. Démonstration :
IA : Comment s'appelle le liquide
présent au fond de l'océan ?
Je sais pas !
IA : Comment s'appelle l'étoile
au centre du système solaire ?
Je sais !
Pour savoir s'il est vrai qu'on
connaît moins bien les fonds marins,
nous avons demandé son expertise d'expert
à une experte des sols et de la géologie
de la Terre. Elle aime lécher des
cailloux et elle a une sœur jumelle
morte qui est reporter de guerre, je vous
présente Valentine de Science de Comptoir !
Bonjour.
Alors Valentine, dites-nous tout...
Tout.
Est-ce que c'est vrai qu'on connaît mieux
le système solaire que le fond des océans ?
C'est vrai.
Mais il paraît que c'est une
zone très difficile à atteindre ?
C'est exact.
Et d'ailleurs, on sait encore très
peu de choses sur cet endroit,
y compris la faune et la flore qui vivent ?
Tout à fait.
Et bien merci Valentine pour cette partie
de ni oui ni non et pour cette expertise
sans précédent. Nous reviendrons peut-être
vous demander votre expertitude dans jamais.
Si on connaît pas très bien du tout les fonds
marins c'est parce que c'est très compliqué d'y
aller. Visiblement c'est plus simple d'envoyer
des gens sur la lune ! lol ! Jusqu'à aujourd'hui
en 2023, en tout 12 hommes ont marché
sur la lune mais seulement 6 hommes et
1 femme ont plongé tout au fond de la fausse des
Mariannes, l'endroit le plus profond des océans.
Un endroit plein de mystères et de pénombre
où la vie semble comme suspendu à un fil...
IA : Au fond de la fosse des Mariannes,
à 10 984 mètres de profondeur, la pression et
1000 fois supérieure par rapport à la surface.
Ca veut dire qu'il faut un bon sous-marin
bien solide qui résiste bien à la pression
sinon on se retrouve face à
un risque de mort important.
IA : Je propose d'envoyer Valentine au fond
de la fosse des Mariannes... pour la science.
Ca manque de subtilité comme projet d'assassinat.
Attendez, je crois que ma sœur Fiona il est déjà !
Elle a l'air de s'y plaire !
La fausse des Mariannes est dans le
Pacifique Nord-Ouest entre les Philippines,
la Papouasie Nouvelle-Guinée et le Japon. Elle
se trouve sur une zone où la plaque tectonique
Pacifique passe sous celle des Philippines et
comme l'a dit l'autre il y a quelques instants,
c'est l'endroit le plus profond de l'océan
connu à ce jour : environ 11 000 mètres de
profondeur. Je suis pas sûr que vous vous rendiez
bien compte de ce que ça représente 11 000 mètres
de profondeur. Vous voyez l'Everest ? C'est un
genre de gros caillou pointu. Bah admettons que
vous le souleviez avec un petit transpalette,
tout ce qu'il y a de plus de transpalette,
et que vous le retourniez dans l'océan. Et
ben on verrait quand même rien dépasser de
l'eau parce que l'Everest et 8 848 mètres
et que le transpalette c'est 1 mètre 20.
Cette fosse, on l'a découverte en 1875.
C'était pendant la toute première campagne
océanique menée par la Royal Navy.
L'objectif était de cartographier
les fonds marins mais le papier
sous l'eau ça tient pas bien.
La première fois que des personnes sont
allées au fond de la fosse des Mariannes
c'était en 1960, soit 9 ans avant le
premier homme sur la Lune. Jacques
Piccard et Don Walsh sont descendus à
10 916 mètres de profondeur. Pour ça,
ils étaient à bord du bathyscaphe "Trieste".
Sur ce, je vais aller lécher des cailloux.
Ne vous inquiétez pas, j'ai bien conscience
que certains d'entre vous ne savent pas ce
qu'est un bathyscaphe. Heureusement je
suis là pour te laisser leur expliquer.
IA : Un bathyscaphe est un sous-marin
d'exploration des grandes profondeurs.
L'appareil a été inventé par Auguste Piccard, le
père de Jacques Piccard. Le mot "bathyscaphe" est
composé de deux mots grecs : "bathus" qui signifie
"profond" et "scaphe" qui signifie "barque".
C'est exactement ça : le profond barque.
On peut ajouter aussi que sur un bathyscaphe, il
y a des caméras, des instruments scientifiques,
des bras robotiques, tout ce qu'il
faut pour faire l'exploration et de
la recherche. Et Auguste Piccard a aussi
inventé le ballon à hydrogène pour aller
explorer la stratosphère. Oh le con ! Il
étudie les fonds marins dans le ciel !
Anecdote : Hergé se serait inspiré de lui pour
créer le professeur Tournesol dans les
aventures de Tintin ! C'est cocasse !
Du coup la fosse des Mariannes c'est un sujet
intéressant parce que pendant des années,
on pensait qu'on y trouverait rien du tout
! Il paraît même qu'on voulait y mettre les
déchets nucléaires hop ni vu ni connu. Sauf
qu'en fait bah il y a de la vie tout au fond
de la mer ! Donc finalement, on enfouit les
déchets nucléaires sous terre parce que sous
terre il y a juste des vers de terre, des pommes
de terre et des taupes de terre donc on s'en fout.
Mais c'est vrai qu'à 11 000 mètres de profondeur
on a du mal à imaginer qu'il puisse y avoir un
début de petite crevettes. Je vous l'ai dit,
la pression y est méga importante ! Et à 200
mètres de profondeur la lumière passe
même plus. A titre personnel j'ai envie
d'appeler ça le mur de Planck des Mariannes
! Oui bah c'est une bague de scientifique.
IA : Absence de lumière ne
signifie pas absence de vie.
Ben oui parce que sinon Louis Braille
il serait déjà mort depuis longtemps !
En 1960 alors qu'un petit club de crevettes se
baladait au fond de la fausse des Mariannes,
sans doute dans l'objectif d'aller à la mer entre
copines, un objet non d'identifié avec son bord
deux spécimens d'une espèce inconnue,
a fait irruption sur son territoire.
Oh mon dieu Yvette ! Mais qu'est-ce que c'est que
ce truc immense qui descend du plafond d'eau !?
J'en sais rien Bernadette, je
n'avais jamais vu ça avant !
Mais quelle horreur il y a des
choses vivantes à l'intérieur !
On dirait un bocal à humains rouges ! Mais il
y aurait de la vie dans le plafond d'eau !?
Attends Yvette, demandons à Nicolas le
poisson plat, il est expert en vie inconnu !
Nicolas le poisson plat qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette chose qui vient de
débarquer du plafond d'eau ?
Il semblerait qu'il s'agisse d'une
nouvelle espèce ! Appelons-la : humain.
Nicolas le poisson plat comment fais-tu pour fumer
ta pipe sous l'eau ? Elle devrait s'éteindre !
Tu as raison Bernadette, je fume
du tabac mouillé depuis des années
mais il n'existe pas encore de cigarette
électronique qui fonctionne sous l'eau !
IA : Pendant leur expédition au
fond de la fosse des Mariannes,
Jacques Piccard et Don Walsh ont croisé des
crevettes et une espèce de poisson plat inconnue.
Oh Nicolas le poisson plat, je dois
avouer que je t'ai toujours aimé ! Tu
es si intelligent et j'aime
les poissons intelligents !
Oh Bernadette j'aime les petites crevettes dans
ton genre !
Epouse-moi !
T'étais pas censée partir toi ?
Si mais j'ai une attirance
profonde pour les gens malaisants.
Il y a donc de la vie au fond de la fosse des
mariages... des Mariannes ! Des Mariannes.
De la vie bien différente de ce qu'on a
l'habitude de voir à la surface de l'eau.
Parce que sans lumière et donc sans végétaux,
les habitants des fonds marins se nourrissent
de quoi ? Et bah principalement de
ce qu'on appelle la neige abyssale.
Oh là là mais il faut vraiment réparer ce
plafond d'eau, voilà qu'il neige abyssale !
Ne vous inquiétez pas Madame
Yvette, je vais vous réparer ça !
Mais vous n'êtes pas le bon requin outil...
Ahah !
En gros la neige abyssale, ce sont tous
les restes organiques qui viennent de la
surface. D'autres espèces vont plutôt
filtrer le sable pour trouver des
restes. Et d'autres mangent les carcasses
d'animaux morts quand ils en trouvent.
Hé pas touche à ma jumelle morte !
Non mais genre des baleines.
Oui bah c'est bien ce que je dis !
Et du coup ces charognards ne se déplacent
pas très vite pour éviter de cramer toutes
leurs réserves énergétiques. Parce que oui, une
carcasse de baleine ça tombe pas tous les jours
du ciel d'eau. Parmi les espèces incroyables qu'on
retrouve dans la fosse des Mariannes, il y a par
exemple l'incroyable poisson revenant. Et même que
quand vous le remontez à la surface il explose !
IA : Le poisson revenant, ou barreleye
du Pacifique ou Macropinna microstoma,
est un poisson mesurant 15 cm de long. Il fait
partie de la famille des Opisthoproctidae.
Les Opisthomachins se sont des poissons qui ont
une tête transparente, littéralement, on voit leur
globe oculaire à travers c'est dégueulasse.
Et donc oui ils font bien 15 centimètres.
Autre espèce des abysses un peu moins
dégueulasse mais plutôt effrayante : la
baudroie abyssale. Avec sa lanterne-là et plein
de dents dans sa bouche. Et bien sachez que
cette espèce a une méthode de reproduction
des plus romantiques ! Les femelles mesurent
environ 20 centimètres alors que le mal ne
dépasse pas les 3 centimètres. Loser ! Le
petit mâle va se fixer sur la femelle
puis fusionner avec elle pour une vie
pleine d'amour, de passion et de fusion
! On appelle ça le parasitisme sexuel.
Oh arrête de me parasiter Nicolas !
Mais moi je veux faire l'amour !
Autre espèce bien dégueulasse et extrêmement
connue : le blobfish. Ce poisson a une
apparence flasque, des os tous mous, aucune
musculature, une chair de faible densité,
il n'a pas de dents et il se nourrit de
neige sous-marine. Les scientifiques se
demandent comment il fait pour supporter la
pression de l'environnement dans lequel il vit.
Autre espèce plutôt effrayante : le requin
lutin, qui n'a rien à voir avec un lutin.
Je sais pas pourquoi ils l'ont appelé
comme ça mais c'est complètement con.
IA : Le requin lutin, ou Mitsukurina
owstoni, a un long museau plat doté de capteurs
électriques pour mieux détecter ses proies.
Il a la capacité de propulser sa mâchoire vers
l'avant c'est dégueulasse. Il peut faire jusqu'à
6 mètres de long et très lent parce qu'il
y a de toutes petites nageoires. Il n'a
jamais connu de mutation génétique au fil du
temps on appelle ça une espèce panchronique.
Et pour finir, une espèce unique
en son genre qu'on a observé qu'une
seule fois à 10 898 mètres de
profondeur : le James Cameronus.
En 2012, le réalisateur américain
réalise non pas Titanic 2 mais un
rêve : atteindre le fond de la fosse des
Mariannes. Alors évidemment ce n'était
pas juste un caprice de personnes
riches, de réaaaaal qui travaille
dans le cinochaaaaaan. C'était dans le
cadre d'une expédition scientifique.
IA : L'expédition a été l'occasion de collecter
des spécimens marins destinés à être étudiés par
des biologistes, des exobiologistes,
des géologues et des géophysiciens.
Et il faut continuer à étudier nos fonds
marins parce qu'on les connaît pas bien et
comme on les connaît pas bien on risque
de faire n'importe quoi ! Vous saviez
qu'on a retrouvé du plastique à
11 000 mètres de profondeur !?
Oui.
Ah ! T'as perdu ! Au ni oui ni non...
Merci Valentine pour son expertise du jour ! Nous
ne manquerons pas de la revoir
dans une prochaine vidéo !
Si cet épisode pas du tout spatial vous
a plu, ne manquez pas de nous le faire
savoir ! Et on pourra sans doute faire
d'autres épisodes pas du tout spatiaux qui
vous plaisent et que vous ne manquerez pas
de nous le faire savoir dès la saison 4...